it's a need for you guys to have a
marriage contract or a prenup in the
laws of america that's a necessity
especially when you're coming into a
marriage and you have no assets
who are coming into a marriage without
no assets well let's talk about blouse x
shahidah
during the tell-all nothing got solved
between you and shahida shaida i know
you probably can't tell us but just
tease where do things stand with you in
shahidah now
well we are cordial you know pretty sick
of the children you have to be cordial
because sometimes the bigger picture is
you focus on your children so despite if
you're feeling some type of way you try
to put your differences aside just to be
cautious with the person which i have
been you know have been doing it's hard
you know by the same time i am looking
at this as oh this is i'm in a family
unit now bilal doesn't come with himself
he called me children so i cannot
be you know too loud or not spoken and
disrespectful so for the sake of the
kids and for the sake of having a
peaceful family life she and i are
cordial
cardiologists
good morning good evening and goodbye
okay
bilal what do you think is the root
issue here but when it all boils down to
it between shaida and shahida
what's the problem
because the prenup has been signed
um
you know i don't i tend not to
you know um i've been taught long ago
like not telling him i was a man not to
get into women's you know issues but
i could just try to
convey to you know my wife you know that
you know how much she means to me and
things like that and you know like
whether i don't care whoever it is you
know like when you know because you know
it could be this person one day it could
be another person the next day like you
know try not to let anybody or any
circumstance or situation you know take
you out of your character you know and
take you out of who you are though as a
person and you know continue being
the light that you are
yeah
i don't want to cause any disturbance
but i have to ask because i feel like
fans want this follow-up question do you
feel like shahida was in the wrong or is
in the wrong for how she's approached
shaida do you see areas where she
should have done better
yeah i think but yeah i mean i think
that you know
i would assume and i've heard no i
mentioned like she she would have she
could have done things better definitely
than you know the way that
uh you know she
talked to shy
and
you know sometimes um
i don't like
a person can have you know maybe
i don't like different attentions but
they you know
how they come across is you know could
be aggressive you know and
you know and i and i think that you know
um
what was done could have been done a lot
better you know um
came at you know my wife uh
you know so that's again my tool
my wife one more time
i think it's about you know just respect
to you know that um
you know i respect you know her as the
mother my children uh respect her her
husband you know and you know their
relationship
and you know um
right just having the same respect as
well you know for my wife and for our
relationship
because at the end of the day it's about
our children you know having a healthy
blended
family from a viewer standpoint it seems
as if she's getting used to someone
another woman a main woman
in your life what it's been 10 years
well no i mean i've so there's another
misconception that i i've never talked
to anybody since i was divorced i'm
talking to you some
incredible
sorry babe but some incredible thing you
know um
things just didn't know transpire and
work out but you know there were you
know some great women you know along the
way that just got a chance to get to
know and be in relationships with
um but you know
meeting my my wife or before you know
like when we first met like you know
like she was somebody who we just
connected immediately and
flew out to trinidad and all that and
um and obviously you know we got married
now but i think it's just the dynamic of
you know like oh you know you know
seeing somebody and
i don't know um i mean she's always said
she couldn't wait for me to get married
i think more so don't for the children
because you know it's helpful for the
children to see not just mom married but
now seeing dad mary because marriage is
something that was really really
something that was always important as
it wasn't still for me and my family and
our religion
and for both of us as well so for us to
to connect and get married you know
something that um
not just good for us but also for you
know
our children and god with our future
children
likes the practice we're blessed yeah
that he doesn't i think after practicing
something should yeah like you want to
see something right we've been apart for
so long i'm like let's enjoy each other
for a little bit yeah how long has a
little bit like you know two years we
gotta talk about the pregnancy journey
i know i know i know so
this season happily ever after
what can you tease
are we is there going to be some good
news eventually or are we still hitting
roadblocks below are you still stuck on
two years from now
i was i was never stuck on two years
that was something that she brought to
the table she once said 40 etc so i just
agreed to it however what i have
said
was i said it would be nice because i
think what a lot of times people forget
is that
me and shy had the least amount of time
together than any other couple that we
were on the show like they would we
spent literally seven days together
physically that was it prior to her
coming to america so it was more so like
let us give a chance to be together
spend more time with each other get to
know each other more even have more life
experiences more
there is a long list of things that my
wife wants to do
and um and i'm just trying to fulfill
some of them before you know we bring
life into the world because it's not
that we can't do any of it it's just
that um you know
i'm speaking from experience too that
you know life does change drastically
when you do bring you know you just
can't pick up and go to the concert
tonight or because a lot of you know
most of my family don't live here yeah
and
you know four is not just having anybody
watch your child a babysitter you know
things things change so you're gonna see
a lot of that play off but happily ever
after like
that is one thing i can't convince him
to do immediately
he's still giving me those word vlogs
yeah well i know science has progressed
so there are there are options but it's
also cutting it close do you have any
anxiety
shout out about time running out uh i
think you will see a lot of the anxiety
payoff for halfway around it's gonna be
so real because it's like this is like
i'm not i'm 28 now so it's like oh my
god two years away from 40 what's going
to happen next so
ah and i'm aware of all that i'm i want
to give her everything that she wants
and more it is when my sweet handsome
husband will be ready
i just don't want if we do you know
conceive
right now like that she would take
because it happens
be honest with you but i love everybody
she
take take the aggression of all the
things she didn't want to do like her
business
i'm heavily involved trying to help her
establish that
like to take those things out on me
because
you know things change her body change
and you know now we have a child and
that's also expecting the worst to below
i could travel i could juggle all those
things i'm just i mean i'll be a super
mom postpartum is real you know
that's true you know and i just want i'm
here for you
and i just also don't want to be beat up
too much and backlash you know folks
you know because you
she would always send me like
messages dms of like stuff like she
wants to do before she came to america
you know i'm just trying to try to
fulfill him
yeah well there are some fans who think
you secretly sniff yourself
i've i've heard them too i've heard it
here's the funny thing is that um one
i'm black i'm african-american uh
it's hard enough to get an
african-american male to go to the
doctor so you tell them
sniffing his manhood that's the
unfortunate truth you know we don't we
typically don't do that
let alone muslim too so the rumors and
stuff were pretty funny
yeah
you